filmmaker oliver stone says americans do
not have a full picture of russian
president vladimir putin
he aims to change that with a new
project the putin interviews
the four-part documentary includes
several conversations with the russian
president
they were shot over the course of two
years in one discussion
pollutant talks to stone about multiple
assassination attempts
but he is not worried about his safety
and in 2012 you run for president
and you win by 63 percent yeah you're
right
three times president five assassination
attempts i'm told
not as much as castro who i've
interviewed
i think he must have had fifty but
there's a legitimate five i've heard
about
yesterday
doesn't
and they've done a great job because
always the first mode of assassination
you try to get inside the security of
the of the president
[Music]
[Music]
a lot of people would like to have two
hours with vladimir putin at this moment
yeah to talk to him even though this
took place over two years
fascinating when he says those who are
destined to be hanged are not going to
drown
very interesting i'm very curious to see
the rest of what he has to say yeah we
will see well charlie you've talked to
him i have indeed
um i should say the putin interviews
will be airing monday june 12th on
showtime
a division of cbs this morning oliver
stone
that morning when those go on on
showtime oliver stone will join us right
here in studio 57
so we'll have more of that